Wir sind hier in Accra,
der Hauptstadt von Ghana.
Yo, yo, yo, what's up?
What's up? Check me! Give me hand!
Yo, what's up? What's up?
Ich bin Mathias Schluep.
Ursprünglich
bin ich Umweltingenieur.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Ich bin Spezialist
in Sachen Elektroschrottrecycling.
Die Schweizer Regierung
hat nicht nur mich,
sondern auch unsere Organisation
mit anderen Partnern beauftragt,
in Ghana die Regierung
und andere Partner beim Aufbau
eines nachhaltigen Recyclingsystems
für Elektroschrott zu unterstützen.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
Das ist jetzt der
grösste Secondhand-Markt von Accra
und in dem Sinne wahrscheinlich
auch der grösste von Ghana.
Hier bekommt man fast alles.
Hello! I'm Mathias!
In Europa, in Deutschland,
in Holland gibt es auch ...
Man nennt das
"die ghanaische Diaspora".
Also nicht,
um diese Leute schlechtzumachen.
Sie haben ihre Geschäftsbeziehungen
zu Ghana.
Sie organisieren eigentlich
den Export von gebrauchten Geräten
nach Afrika.
Okay, bye-bye!
- Bye-bye!
Dort ist Tema, der Hafen von Accra.
Es ist einer der grösseren
Handelshäfen oder -zentren
von Westafrika.
Hier werden containerweise
auch Occasionsgeräte verschifft
und gelangen hierher.
Theoretisch dürfte das, was defekt
ist und nicht mehr funktioniert,
eigentlich nicht hierhergelangen.
Gemäss der Basel-Konvention -
das ist eine UN-Konvention,
die auch die Schweiz
unterschrieben hat -
dürfte das nicht hierhergelangen.
Wir haben mal
eine Untersuchung gemacht.
Diese ergab, dass 30 % der Geräte,
die exportiert wurden,
nicht funktionstüchtig waren.
Aber die Hälfte davon
konnte man reparieren.
Und diese hatten nachher
durchaus ein gutes Leben.
Und der Rest, die 15 %,
und das ist eben ein hohes Volumen,
also eine grosse Anzahl
von Elektroschrottgeräten
oder von Elektroschrott,
ist eigentlich illegal ins Land
gekommen, müsste man sagen.
Wir sind hier
in einem sog. Repair Shop.
Das Geschäftsmodell ist so,
dass sie versuchen,
die Geräte zu reparieren.
Sie nehmen vielleicht
aus alten Geräten,
die nicht mehr
funktionstüchtig sind,
ein Teil heraus,
um die Geräte so zusammenzubauen.
Thank you very much!
- Thank you!
Wenn man es
nicht mehr reparieren kann,
sieht man in dem Gerät
immer noch einen Wert:
Es gibt Metalle darin -
wie Kupfer oder Eisen.
In den Leiterplatten von Computern
sind Edelmetalle wie Gold enthalten.
Dann versucht man eben,
an diese Materialien zu kommen.
Dort fangen die Probleme an.
# Welcome to my world.
# Step right through the door.
Hier sind wir jetzt
auf dem Agbogbloshie Scrapyard,
dem Zentrum von Accra,
wo der ganze Schrott zusammenkommt,
wo alle Sammler von Elektroschrott
zusammenkommen,
aber man sieht hier
auch viele Autoteile.
Und hier sieht man die Kehrseite:
Alle Geräte
kommen ans Ende ihres Lebens.
Dann werden sie hier verarbeitet.
Da wird von Hand gearbeitet
und nicht darauf geachtet,
was ins Erdreich ausläuft usw.
Das sind natürlich Bedingungen,
die nicht sein sollten.
Hier sind ganz viele Leute,
die davon leben,
diese Sachen auseinanderzunehmen
und Rohmaterialien zurückzugewinnen.
Diese verkaufen sie dann wieder.
Sie sagen, er könne nicht reden
und nicht hören,
aber er hat hier seinen Job.
Er hat sich
auf diese Motoren spezialisiert
und nimmt sie auseinander.
Er gewinnt das Kupfer zurück.
Diese Kupferspule
ist ein paar Dollar wert.
Dann hat man die Leiterplatte
und die Kabel rundherum.
Das ist eigentlich der ganze Wert
eines
solchen Kathodenstrahlfernsehers.
Und dann gibt es Bleiglas.
Dieses Bleiglas ist nachher
eigentlich das grosse Problem -
wegen der Entsorgung.
Die Sammlerquote in diesen Ländern
ist viel höher
als diejenige in der Schweiz.
D.h., es wird wirklich fast alles
von diesem Abfall eingesammelt.
Kommt noch hinzu:
Es gibt viele arme Leute.
Das ist ganz typisch
für diese Länder.
Arme Leute findet man wirklich ...
Das Ende der Gesellschaft findet man
häufig auf diesen Abfallhalden.
Sie versuchen,
sich ein Leben zu machen,
indem sie den Abfall sortieren
und wertvolle Materialien
daraus entnehmen,
diese wieder verkaufen und so
am Schluss des Tages etwas haben,
womit sie sich
etwas zu essen kaufen können.
Das ist aus dem ganzen Apparat.
Das ist das einzige Teil,
das sie verkaufen können,
weil es einen Abnehmer
für dieses Plastik gibt.
Und der ganze Rest,
der hier auf dem Boden liegt,
geht auf einen Dumpsite.
Es wird auf einen grossen Haufen
geschmissen.
Damit passiert nichts.
Das ist natürlich schlecht.
Das ist das,
was unsere Projekte
auch ändern wollen, dass man sagt:
"Es gibt Entsorgungslösungen
für all diese Abfälle."
Also dass sie nicht
auf diesen Landfills oder Dumpsites
entsorgt werden müssen.
Let's move forward!
Als ich mit dieser Arbeit anfing
und mich damit auseinandersetzte,
hatte ich manchmal
schon schlaflose Nächte,
wenn ich an solchen Orten war,
denn wir sind uns das nicht gewohnt.
Dann sieht man Kinder, die
auf irgendeiner Dumpsite aufwachsen,
und denkt:
"Die haben im Leben
nie eine Chance!"
Und die Leute tun sich
gesundheitlich sozusagen viel an.
Ja, das Ganze ist ein Prozess.
Wir müssen uns bewusst sein:
Auch in Europa gingen wir
durch solche Sachen durch.
Ich denke,
da muss man auch das sehen.
Es ist ein Prozess.
Meine Vision ist,
dass hier auf dem Agbogbloshie
irgendwann
auch eine professionelle
Recyclinganlage steht.
* Sanfte Musik *
So machen sie Aluminimumtöpfe.
Hinter uns werden sie geschmolzen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Das ist ein Produkt, das sinnvoll
ist und das sie hier herstellen.
Das kann man jetzt
sehr positiv werten -
mit all dem Negativen,
das wir gesehen haben.
Das sind auch wieder Sachen, auf
welche die Leute stolz sein können.
Dort hinten
sehen wir jetzt die Lagune
oder den Fluss -
oder was davon übrig bleibt.
Das ist eine Katastrophe.
Wenn wir ins Wasser blicken,
sehen wir einen Müllhaufen.
Das fliesst irgendwann ins Meer.
Das ist natürlich
eine Riesenschweinerei.
Bis man die Geräte
auseinandergenommen hat,
ist es nicht problematisch.
Aber sobald die Leute
das Kupfer zurückgewinnen wollen
und dann ein Kabel vorfinden -
"Da ist Plastik,
so kann ich es nicht verkaufen!" -,
verbrennen sie halt das Kabel,
bis das ganze Plastik verbrannt ist,
und können so
das Kupfer zurückgewinnen.
Der Rauch
ist sicher sehr, sehr schlecht.
Bei der Verbrennung
entstehen Dioxine.
Das ist etwas vom Giftigsten,
das man kennt.
Sie entstehen durch die Verbrennung
gewisser Chemikalien, die drin sind.
Mit Kupfer zusammen
kann Dioxin entstehen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
das Schlimmste von allem.
Theoretisch ist das in Ghana
tatsächlich verboten.
Man darf nicht einfach so
Dinge verbrennen.
Aber hier ist der Vollzug schwierig.
Würde man mit der Polizei kommen,
käme es zu grossen Unruhen,
denn davon
hängen mehrere Tausend Leute ab.
Das ist doch einigermassen heikel.
Also die Vision ist, dass
so ein Agbogbloshie bestehen bleibt,
aber auf eine nachhaltige Art,
also dass auf eine saubere Art
rezykliert wird.
Die Menschen sollen weiterhin
ihr tägliches Einkommen haben,
etwas verdienen und
eine gute Lebensgrundlage haben.
Es soll ihnen
auch sozial besser gehen.
Sie sollen Anschluss an Sozialhilfe,
Gesundheitshilfe usw. haben.
Das ist die Vision.
Und daher versucht unser Projekt,
an verschiedenen Enden zu arbeiten
und einen Beitrag zu leisten.
* Sanfte Popmusik *
Wir gehen zu den Vollzugsbehörden
des Umweltministeriums.
Das ist unser Hauptpartner im
Projekt mit der Schweizer Regierung.
Wir haben heute eigentlich
das erste Steering Comittee,
also den Steuerungsausschuss,
des Projekts in Ghana.
In diesem Steuerungsausschuss
ist das Ministerium selbst dabei,
das Umweltministerium.
Dann ist das Ministerium für Finance
dabei.
Sie regeln die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen den Ländern.
Und die Schweizerische Botschaft
ist dabei.
Wir besprechen das Programm,
das wir für die ganzen vier Jahre
aufgestellt haben.
Das Wichtige ist auch,
dass man die Leute vor Ort
wirklich zu Experten macht,
denn irgendwann endet unser Projekt.
Dann sollten die Resultate
nachhaltig bleiben.
D.h., wir müssen hier
auch die Expertise aufbauen.
Da sind wir ganz zuversichtlich.
Wir haben in unserem Team
sehr gute Leute.
Das sind im Land
schon anerkannte Experten.
Okay, bye! Ciao!
Es kamen noch gute Inputs,
was man noch anders machen
bzw. verbessern könnte.
In dem Sinne habe ich das Gefühl,
dass alle zufrieden rausgingen.
Wir wissen auch,
wie wir weiterfahren müssen.
Das ist wichtig.
Wenn man in solchen Projekten
arbeitet und auch sieht,
was deren Auswirkung
in anderen Ländern sein kann,
überlegt man sich selbst
natürlich auch,
wie man mit diesen Konsumgütern
umgeht.
An einem Black Friday
sollte man vielleicht überlegen:
"Muss man es wirklich kaufen,
nur weil es 100 Fr. billiger ist?"
Man hat dann immer das Gefühl,
man habe 100 Fr. gespart,
aber wenn man das Gerät
gar nicht braucht,
hat man vielleicht
zu viel Geld ausgegeben,
auch wenn es 100 Fr. billiger war.
Wir sagen ja immer:
"Das sind Entwicklungsländer."
Also "unterentwickelt"
sagt man im Prinzip nicht mehr,
aber das meint man damit.
Dann frage ich mich,
ob wir nicht
etwas überentwickelt sind.
Ich habe durchaus das Gefühl,
dass man, wenn man hierherkommt,
von diesen Leuten
auch etwas lernen kann.
Darum sagen wir
bei unseren Projekten:
Es ist ein Austausch.
Es ist ein sog. Knowledge Exchange.
D.h., wir wollen auch von hier
etwas lernen.
Sie können von uns etwas lernen.
Dann müssen wir uns
in der Mitte treffen,
um die idealen Lösungen zu finden.
Aber ich nehme auch durchaus
etwas mit nach Hause und sage:
"Es ist wahnsinnig,
was die können und machen."
"Warum machen wir das nicht?"